did i ever tell you what the definition
of insanity is
oh no
insulin
is
doing the exact
same thing over and over again
expecting
to change
oh my god this is terrifying
that is crazy
alrighty folks we're back it's a new
year and my producers have not stopped
the torture in the new year we are going
to be analyzing some woke tick tock
videos yet again it's 2022 the torture
continues this video is sponsored by
expressvpn
[Music]
that can't be real there's no way that's
real
greetings earthling my name is darth
vader i come from the planet vulcan
yeah man new york they say there's
florida man new york man is worse than
florida man it is not close
baby
[Music]
we're gonna get it soon and then we can
play
yay
i'm so excited we will get to playing
together when it's done the shot we will
get to play together when it's done that
shot we will get oh my god together this
is terrifying to play together we will
get to play together when it's done the
shot
that
is terrifying who made that that's
that's terrifying that's a okay it's a
person from instagram for a second i
thought it was just actually made by the
cdc is there anything less geared toward
not scaring children than that it's like
pennywise the clown we will get to play
together after you get the shot here's a
shiny balloon
what was that what was that
hi my name's becca i'm the host of the
system
hi i'm bella i don't really know what
role i have in the system because
i am a new alter so
hey my name
[Music]
what's up it's jamie i'm the primary
protector of the system
we took our meds a while ago so i'm
groggy
hi my name is vega i am the sexual
protector of the system
hey i'm kai i am a trauma holder and
gatekeeper for the system i work very
closely with another altered nick hell
yeah who is an internal uh caretaker he
does not really front this is a
diagnosable mental disorder it is also
incredibly rare so either this person
has a deep abiding mental disorder that
should not be on tick tock or this
person is just mimicking having a deep
abiding mental disorder which probably
is another form of mental disorder it's
your classic cry for attention honestly
i can't even laugh at that because that
is so deeply disturbing on every level
there's a person who needs help and
instead they will get lulls and clicks
on tick-tock it's amazing you know as a
society we went from we had 200 years
ago 150 years ago circus freaks and
circus freaks were people who are
different than everybody else and you
would literally pay at the circus to see
them and then we realized as a society
this is very bad and we shouldn't really
be doing this because after all these
are people very often who are suffering
who have some sort of condition and
honestly nobody should be treated with
pure laughter just because of a
condition that they cannot control and
now it seems like we are directly
back to the circus because people are
posting their own stuff on tick tock for
the laws and the clicks and the
attention we have gone quite downhill in
this society over the course the last 20
years in the name of diversity tolerance
and acceptance we'll get to more woke
tick tock in just one moment first using
the internet without expressvpn it's a
really really bad idea because there are
lots of people who want your information
every time you connect to an unencrypted
network cafes hotels airports any hacker
on the same network can gain access to
your personal data we're talking
passwords financial details everything
hackers can make up to a thousand bucks
per person selling personal information
on the dark web so i use expressvpn
every single time i go online because it
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet
hackers cannot steal my sensitive data
it would take a hacker with a super
computer over a billion years to get
past expressvpn's encryption that's how
good the encryption is and here's the
thing it's super easy to use this is the
thing i like the very best so i open up
my phone all i have to do is go on over
to the express vpn app go like this link
open it up not connected but then i hit
the button and within like two seconds
i'm connected it is indeed that simple
it can be that easy for you as well
phones laptops tablets everything you
can stay secure on the go using
expressvpn so go check them out right
now secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com
ben yt that's expressvpn.com
benytexpressvpn.com
ben yt get an extra three months for
free expressvpn.com
ben yt
man i didn't think
2022 was gonna start off this dope
but damn it didn't start off awesome
watch this
[Music]
that is a person who is very
enthusiastic about a twitter suspension
i'm not sure that i've ever seen another
human being as happy as that which means
that this person is really kind of sad
first of all good indicator this person
has bad judgment is that he has a poster
from the m night shyamalan movie signs
behind him i'm losing my mind that's a
that's an
odd movie pick but beyond that why are
you so excited about marjorie taylor
green being suspended i've never been
that's excited about anything that's
happened online ever in my entire life
and i spend half of my life online
wow all right so i'm at the store trying
to shop right now
no pictures in the store oh it's not a
picture it's a video you would not keep
your mask up now it is up for the video
no no here please read the story i was
trying to smell these candles here to
shop at uh dollarama here
as i pull my mask down to smell
and now i have another guy
yelling at me over here to put my mask
up
unbelievable man bring that knot down i
literally was trying to smell like a
candle you were in yours and then you
were abusive to me your staff started
shouting actually and so is your stuff
okay so canada first of all is that
canadian flag right there yeah we need
to invade our neighbor to the north to
re-establish freedom we'll be greeted as
liberators they're not even a real
country anyway so the guys smell the
candle and people are yelling people
have lost their minds they've absolutely
lost their minds they've lost it i would
guarantee you that the guy who's yelling
at him about masking is quadruple vexed
quinn tuple of acts sex tuple of axe
infinity that and they're all freaking
out for no reason at all again because
the evidence when it comes to some of
these masks is uh scanty and beyond that
you're not like how's he supposed to
smell your candle again it's his store
he can do what he wants also
that guy is uh disconnected from reality
that story is disconnected from reality
oh no i don't know if i was clear the
first time when i said it so i'll be
clear again this time okay my gender is
i mean okay
okay this is maybe the only time in
human history well i will use the
alternative pronoun because it does seem
as though you are um
a demon yeah honestly more of this uh
more of this more of this in public
society because i want to know who the
insane people around me are if i see a
resume and it says bob smith preferred
pronouns oh
then i know who not to hire so thank you
for selecting out of our employment pool
thank you for that i really appreciate
it
[Music]
these are all fake tweets ben dover
now look at the next one cnn's thrown
out fake twitter names mike sloan
this is cnn you think that they'd have
someone screening this who's this
one i need a black man
what the
is that real
if that's real then um yeah cnn
most trusted name
in news you know what you can kiss my
behind i do not care they're great
at this they're so they're wow
wow good stuff happening over at tnn so
broad takeaway
why
why god
why why every day we stray further from
god's light now there have been rumors
that tick-tock is basically just a
chinese front to destroy the west well
let's put it this way if it were a
chinese front to destroy the west would
it look any different than it looks
right now because
my god
alrighty well if you enjoyed watching me
suffer then leave us a comment below
also make sure that you subscribe and
leave us a review we really do
appreciate it and we'll see you here
next time when my producers torture me
with something worse than
gitmo